in meiner Stadt gibt es an jeder Ecke
Döner und das überall und jederzeit
dachte ich zumindest aber fangen wir von
vorne an ein Freund hat mir erzählt dass
es irgendwo in Köln Ehrenfeld scheinbar
einen geheimen Döner gibt den es nur an
einem Tag für wenige Stunden in einem
Hinterhof gibt und das klingt nach einer
Sache die ich einfach testen muss das
einzige Problem ich weiß nicht wo es ihn
gibt wann es ihn gibt und für wie viele
Stunden und eine Frage bleibt wenn es
ihn gibt ist er überhaupt gut viele
Sachen die wir herausfinden müssen ich
habe schon eine Idee ich rufe einen
Kumpel von mir an den Jakob den ja auch
aus anderen Videos kennt denn wenn es
einer weiß ob es diesen Döner hier gibt
dann er der kennt sich richtig gut aus
in Köln und das klingt alles viel zu
verrückt um wahr zu sein rufen wir
einfach mal an hey Bro du ich habe eine
Frage du als alter Kölner ne ich habe
von einem Dönerladen gehört der sich
irgendwo in Ehrenfeld befinden soll der
ein keine Ahnung geheimen Döner verkauft
hast du davon schon mal gehört als
allererstes ich habe nicht nur davon
gehört ich habe auch schon gegessen aber
würdest du sagen dass es sich lohnt den
Döner zu testen ist irgendwie besonders
ja auf jeden Fall okay das ist schon mal
gut zu wissen ich glaube dann müssen wir
ihn auf jeden Fall testen was hast du
gerade vor Bro bist du gerade busy ich
bin busy aber ich k es einrichten 20
Minuten geil okay ja wir sind ready dann
testen c c geil Alter ohne Witz wir
machen das jetzt Jakob weiß wo den Döner
gibt damit ist die halbe Miete getan ich
hoffe es lohnt sich und ich hoffe der
Döner ist wirklich gut ichin Ernst
gespannt jetzt ne ich auch da vorne
kommt Jakob let's go und Jakob war das
schon mal sag mal also Ehre dass das so
klappt mein lieber du warst schon dort
ja ich war schon dort ist es so ein Ding
was keiner kennt oder kennt man das in K
W sagen so Ehrenfelder kennen das schon
aber kann sein es geht nicht so über die
stadtviertelgrenzen hinaus das einzige
was sein könnte wie viel haben wir jetzt
13 Uhr 13 Uhr da könnte jetzt schon eine
dicke Schlange sein also ich glaube das
also es kennen schon Leute wen Ken auf
jeden Fall Leute so vor allem die Leute
die so in der Umgebung arbeiten und
alles spricht sich schon rum und und
auch un Spaß let Mal als ich da war
meine Homi hat drei gegessen sind die
klein oder wie die sind nicht so riesig
auf jeden Fall also der zeichnet sie
jetzt nicht durch seine Größe aus wie
sieht dein Homie
aus ich bin gespannt also es ist schon
mal geil es ist Mittwoch es gibt den
Döner nur Mittwoch wir sind auf dem Weg
dahin und es gibt ihn wirklich
h müs irgendwo sein da rechts ist es da
rechts marktalle Körner das ist der
Laden das sieht übelst unscheinbar aus
diger also nicht dass heute vielleicht
kein Dönerstag ist ne heute ist ja
Mittwoch oder dass es den gar nicht mehr
gibt vielleicht hat sich ja gar nicht
mehr gelohnt das zu machen let mal da
war bestimmt schon Jahr her da erinnere
ich mich auch daran dass der hike nur so
ein Fünfer gekostet hat Bo das W krass
der letzte günstige Döner in Köln
mittlerweile der heute morgen fürs Intro
6,90 € Leben h nicht mehr in 2018 krke
Welt od darf nur 3 € Kosten schülerdöner
250 als ich von der Grund von der
Grundschule nach Hause das war halt aber
so type 2004 habe ich so habe ich so
mein Taschengeld genommen mir
schülerdöner gekauft ich habe letztens
noch mal den Dönermann von damals
getroffen also in meiner Stadt in der
ich damals gelebt habe und hab das dem
erzählt Malu gemerkt sein Herz ging auf
als ich so erzählle ich war als Kind
immer da und habe den Döner gefetzt al
ja das waren noch schöne Zeiten jetzt
keine Kinder mehr unterwegs da in dem
kleinen Dorf und so mehr Kinder machen
ne mehr Kinder machen und mehr Döner
machen mehr Liebe machen und Liebe mit
Döner machen müssen einfach nur noch
diese Straße hier hoch und dann ist der
Döner irgendwann auf der rechten Seite
die Markthalle ist auf der rechten Seite
und bei googleap habe ich gerade schon
gesehen das sah aus wie so ein ein noch
Kölner alle wenn es Döner gibt kommen s
alle wir laufen wirklich einfach in so
eine
Garagen hier steht so
steht ich fühle mich gerade so wie an
ein Ort wo man das ist ein echter geheim
das ist wirklich krass gerade ja Alter
ohne Witz Leute ich bin richtig gespannt
hier stehen bestimmt 30 Leute in der
Schlange einfach für den geheimen Döner
sorry darf ich euch ganz kurz stören
seid ihr öfter hier in der marshalle zum
Döner essen ja ja was macht diesen Döner
so besonders für euch warum kommt ihr
mittwochs hierher um diesen Döner zu
essen und geht nicht schck einfach
geil das schmeckt das schmeckt geil ich
war einmal hier aber also ich Hal
vegetarischen nöne und da ist hab auch
vegetarische Variante Kartoffel und
zucini und Paprika auch also einfach
mega geil also geil ja
deswegen wir sind gespannt die Mädels
meinten hier gibt auch eine krasse
vegetarische Variante wir sind jetzt für
Döner hier auf jeden Fall aber ich
glaube das ist allgemein echt guter Tipp
hier also kriegst wahrscheinlich einfach
SAS schnelles ehrliches zu
essen
stimmt das dass ihr nur Mittwochs hier
seid nur Mittwoch Normalbetrieb ist halt
metzkerei und Gemüsehandel normal auch
diese die gleiche Schlange oder ist das
nur Mittwochs das ist Moment ist das
immer so ihr erinnert euch ja der
Kollege von Jakob hat drei Döner
gegessen ich habe hier vor mir direkt
mal sechs stehen aber nicht nur für mich
sondern ich habe auch noch ein paar
Jungs dabei wir lassen es uns jetzt
schmecken Jungs gönnt
euch was wir jetzt trotzdem müssen ist
das Ganze neutral neutral und ehrlich
weil die ganze Geschichte bis hierher
war so geil es hat so viel Spaß gemacht
dass man den Döner schon überbewerten K
allein deshalb aber wir testen das Ding
können erstmal analysieren ja guckt euch
das mal an das wirklich es passt so gut
mit diesem nostalgiedöner den ich vorhin
beschrieben habe so aus meiner Kindheit
weil sieht genauso aus schöne Pele
bisschen Sesam oben drauf und G
komliziiert aus kein selbstgebackenes
Brot aber schön knusprig angetastet und
ich sag dir muss auch nicht immer sein
Bro im Gegensatz zu vielen anderen
Dönern der ist gar nicht so überfüllt
der der ist richtig leer ist richtig
dünn das stimmt 100% deswegen kann ich
schon verstehen dass man mehr als einen
davon essen könn 5 € 5 € ist todesfair
wo kriegst du heute noch ein Döner für 5
€ das stimmt
[Musik]
probier boah crazy ohne Witz diese viele
ich finde das ich finde die besser als
manchen selbstgebackenes Brot das ist
ein richtig geiler Cleaner nostalgischer
Döner nicht überladen bisschen frisches
Gemüse gut abgestimmt ist krass bisschen
klein aber sehr gut er wirkt schon klein
also man kann locker zwei Essen ist gar
keine Frage so jetzt wo alle gegessen
haben darf ich auch mal reinbeißen das
ist wirklich also so flach hat ewig
nicht mehr ein Döner in der
Hand geil Alter das lamfleisch kommt
richtig krass durch finde ich ja und was
man auf jeden Fall merkt dass der
andereung ganz viele andere Döner D den
selberpieen ich kann mir sehr gut
vorstellen wirklich so eine eigene
gewürzrezeptur haben Traum ja
okay leckerer Döner aber kein
Traum ichin TR die Stimme der Vernunft
die Leute
kommentarib wird nicht
weniger oder aus dem fantasiaaland oder
so nach Hause geh irgendwie krass hier
ich weiß auch nicht und die Schlange
wird nicht weniger nehmen also das war
mal was oder das war wirklich geil Jakob
ich danke dir dass du mir das gezeigt
hast gerne gerne wir holen uns noch ein
Kaffee und dann sehen wir uns gleich im
Büro wieder weil das hat was mit mir
gemacht da will ich euch was zu
sagen da sind wir wieder Leute wieder
zurück im Studio und was war das für ein
Erlebnis ich bin ganz ehrlich der Döner
hätte nicht mal so gut schmecken müssen
damit das ein geiler Tag war weil diese
ganze Erfahrung den zu suchen zu finden
und am Ende dann diesen Döner in der
Hand zu haben das war einfach nice es
hat richtig Spaß gemacht ich hoffe ihr
hattet auch ganz viel Spaß und wer weiß
vielleicht motiviert euch das ja auch in
Zukunft mal die Augen offen zu halten
und vielleicht auch in den unscheinbaren
Ecken nach coolen Spots zu suchen die
ihr mal testen könnt falls euch das
Video gefallen hat dann lasst gerne ein
Like und ein Abo da wir sehen uns beim
nächsten Video wieder bis dahin macht's
gut ciao ciao